no better place to end up this uh
fabulous morning with you guys than rock
and roll all night would you say that's
the song The Closer if you will for kiss
when they do a live show you can't end
the night with something better than
that because that really encapsulates
everything we've always been about we've
been all over the world a lot of
languages a lot of cultures when that
song comes up everybody knows the words
Howard you know this one this is rock
and roll
party every day
hey
[Music]
guys
keep on shouting
[Music]
every day
crazy
[Music]
things
every day
[Music]
[Applause]
come on yeah
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
boys what a morning
foreign